Disk I/O virtualization works quite similarly. Every VM has an I/O
ring which is dedicated for disk I/O. This is an I/O ring associated
with VM1. This is an I/O ring associated with VM2.
Similar to network virtualization. Here also, the
communication between the guest operating system and then strives
to avoid copying altogether. No copying into xen
because what we're doing is we are entering
descriptors for the disk I/O that we want
to get done with pointers. To the guest
operating system buffers, where the data is already
contained and the transfer has to go into
the disk. Or a placeholder for the data
to come into from the disk. And the philosophy
being asynchronous I/O. Enqueuing these descriptors
into these I/O ring by the guest
operating system happens asynchronously with respect
to xen enqueuing responses back for prior
requests coming from this VM. Since xen is in charge of the actual devices,
in particular in this case, the disk subsystem. It may reorder requests
from competing domains in order to make the I/O throughput
efficient. But there may be situations where such a request reordering may
be inappropriate from the semantics of the I/O operation. And
therefore, xen also provides a reorder barrier for guest operating
systems to enforce that do this operations in exactly the order
in which I've given them. Such a
reorder barrier for instance may be necessary for
higher level semantics such as right ahead,
logging, and things like that. So that completes
discussion of all the subsystems that need to be virtualized, whether it is by a
fully virtualized environment or a para virtualized environment.
Next, we will talk about usage and billing.